mecha godzilla is the main villain from
the movie godzilla vs kong
and is now considered to be one of the
most powerful titans in the monster
monsterverse
if not the most powerful it is also the
second
biggest statement right after king
ghidorah which cements it as one of the
biggest robots slash
meccas in fiction but there are bigger
ones
and so on this list we will showcase the
10 robots from movies and games
that are bigger than mechagodzilla by
the way it is
by far the biggest incarnation of mega
godzilla even topping over
supermaker godzilla from the touhou
movies but
before we go deeper into this video do
remember to click that subscribe button
to be a part of the mind cue family
so now let's get down with this sickness
number 10 cyberking from doctor who a
cyber king was a massive bipedal robot
controlled by a living being
these ships were used to lead invasions
of cybermen by destroying
cities and mass upgrading their
populations
they were one of the cybermen's most
powerful if not the most powerful weapon
in combat the cyberking had some
components similar to victorian
machinery
and to the extent that it appeared to be
powered by steam engines
with smoke stacks protruding from their
shoulders
a cyberking is around 200 meters or 656
feet tall
around 200 feet taller than mecca g
number nine vana boris from legend of
zelda
avana boris is a mechanical construct in
the legend of zelda series
of games specifically from the breath of
the wild
avanaborus bears the likeness of both
species of camels the bactrian of asia
and the dromedary of africa it is
relatively slender and has
proportionately long legs like the
dromedary and
has two humps on its back like the
bactrim avanaboro's
robot is made from the tech of the
shadowful
their ancient sheikha technology
avanaboros or
also called the divine beast stands at
around 200 meters tall
or 656 feet the same as the cyberking
number 8 mauler from killzone the mother
which stands
around 280 or 918
feet tall it is less of a mech and more
of a battleship
it is possibly the largest helgas and
land vehicle encountered during the
second extra solo war
this robot is seen in the game kill zone
played in playstation
an all-sized mauler is highly armored
and it can withstand even the most
powerful assaults
its structure is also extremely
resilient allowing it to continue to
function
and fire even after being severely
damaged
utilized for both anti-ground and
anti-air operations with
a variety of mounted weapons a single
mauler
is capable of combating entire
battalions
number 7 the galactic colossus from
supreme commander 2
the aeon experimental assault bot also
known as the galactic colossus
and formerly as the sacred assault bot
is the aeon's most effective fighting
machine
the galactic colossus is like mostly
experimental units
and is huge and amphibious crushing any
smaller unit
or structure it walks over while being
still able to walk on the ocean floor to
meet its target
the galactic colossus stands 290 meters
tall
or 951 feet and can deal massive damage
and take
a massive beating before going down
number six the driller from transformers
drillers are cybertron's largest
subterranean lifeforms
they are massive multi-technical beasts
capable of easily burrowing through the
earth
or through walls and they are capable of
massive destruction and carnage on any
scale
they are semi-sentient and can only
follow basic commands
they also cultivate a strong sense of
devotion and loyalty to their masters
they are base of burden mainly used for
mining jobs however the one owned by
shockwave is bred specifically for
militaristic use
and is considerably larger than any
typical member of its species
it is 1080 feet long
number five the grand near from automata
this is a machine life form of extreme
size that was developed
specifically to annihilate androids
however
due to its tendency to also attack its
fellow machines
it was eventually discarded into the sea
uh the part that was initially thought
to be its entire body turned out to be
merely its head causing this colossus to
reach over 1000 meters
or 3280 feet into the sky when standing
straight
and it is seemingly invincible due to
powerful emp defenses
and thick armor the unit was eventually
destroyed when missiles are shut
straight into its mouth
number four the guardian from halo 5.
guardian custodies are commonly known
simply as guardians
are powerful for runner constructs the
body
of a guardian ka story is variable and
ever changing
shaping itself to all inspire and
maximize effectiveness of all defense
systems
generally guardians have a segmented
body and can elaborate
they have phoenix like wings consisting
of multiple segments
the guardians are enormous constructs
measuring
just over 1 412 meters
of 4 635 feet in height with a mass of
200 million metric tons
number three the reapers from mars
effect
well the reapers are a synthetic organic
starship race with advanced technology
the reapers live in a vast space a
largely stylish space between galaxies
known as
the dark space before returning to the
galaxy they hibernate
there for 50 000 years at a time these
giant machines are
ancient and their true name is unknown a
reaper is essentially
billions of organic mines uploaded and
conjoined
within immortal machine bodies they
resemble a cuttlefish
or a squid with a bulky semi-cylindrical
body
and tapering plate over the rear and
five tentacle-like arms
in addition to its six jointed legs
extending from its body
and they are over two kilometers tall
number two the matanui from bionicle a
matanui was a great spirit set to
explore and observe the galaxy
for a time he was doomed to an
everlasting slumber and manitoba
embarked on
quests to bring him back to life by the
way torah were biomechanical
beings who were depicted as heroes and
each tower had a
an elemental skill and they were
powerful mars
while controlling the great spirit robot
matanui possessed several abilities
it possessed the ability to fly fire
blasts of energy from its bombs and
to manipulate gravity this robot was
four million feet tall
or 12 192 kilometers
almost the size of earth and number one
unicron from transformers the last
knight here in the last knight movie
it is revealed that earth is formally
known as unicron
and since earth is unicron cybertron's
enemy world
earth has attracted many inhabitants of
the planet cybertron
the transformers throughout history and
it is unknown as to how unicorn would
look in a transformers live-action film
and we won't know in any way since it is
cancelled but
this is for sure it is as big as the
planet earth
or even bigger and which will put him
around
12 800 kilometers tall in the last night
we see unicron's horns has risen over
the crust
but the initial hexagonal configuration
of the horns
had been lost to randomness due to blade
tectonics
and so with that we come to the end of
this video do like for support and hit
that subscribe button to be a part of
the minecube family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates on new monsterverse
content
godzilla vs common dissection videos gvk
kingdom kong and godzilla dominion
topics as well
take care fam